qui dit printemps du temps des sucres
pour notre retour dans le passé on se
transporte à la fin des années 70 au
cours de cette décennie là les
érablières subissent des transformations
technologiques majeures on abandonne peu
à peu les chevaux et les sauts pour se
tourner vers un nouveau système de
récolte de l'eau d'érable
[Musique]
les tuyaux de plastique compte envahi
lentement mais sûrement nos érablière au
printemps dès que les érables se
réveille on pèse maintenant sur un
bouton et la pompe à vide c'est la
récolte dans le sous bois le coup d'oeil
n'est pas le même et la poésie on est
presque disparue v4 petit et radiateurs
htv tout englober en enfer eu une assez
grosse pour voir jouer le lendemain avec
la turbulence vacuum style de jeu prêté
en bas du dos bonne foi puis la qualité
que sur la qualité ça se compare pas
c'est beaucoup meilleurs lots sur hypo à
part d'un tuyau gaza revient de suite
dans l'être dans la province ailleurs
c'est ce qui chacun ont fait la
meilleure qualité incendiaires prospère
chauffent au soleil puis pendant chasse
au gaspi de l'eau d'érable
il y a évidemment moyen de faire du bon
sirop à la chaudière à condition de les
vider à temps mais si les tubulures
améliore le rendement allant taille
c'est surtout le manque de main d'oeuvre
qui a accéléré l'adoption de cette
technique la population agricole se
trompent nation qui comme un des centres
les le type de producteurs qui
s'adonnent l'exportation de la bielle
est également le moyen d'en avoir
plusieurs plus avancé dans un facteur
déterminant et dans plusieurs cas ça
l'amène les moteurs abandonné de
l'exploitation de la taulière
l'utilisation d'un système mécanisée de
calais est la solution est quasiment la
seule
aujourd'hui au québec plus de 98 % de
l'eau d'érable est acheminée à la cabane
à sucre grâce à un réseau de tubulures
seul hic tout ce plastique a une durée
de vie au bout de 10 à 15 ans il faut
remplacer ses tuyaux chaque année cela
génère trois mille tonnes de déchets
dont seule une petite partie est
recyclée